the traffic stretches back several
kilometers drivers wait for over eight
hours in the blazing sun on this main
road out of donetsk
it's one of the few routes still open
for civilians to reach
government-controlled areas
they have to pass through this ukrainian
military checkpoint it's a painstakingly
slow process
we want to get back home faster we want
this to be more regulated and more
appropriate so that people don't have to
wait for hours in the heat
these are routine journeys family visits
shopping for supplies not available in
conflict areas the delays cause
resentment
there's a feeling that it's being done
on purpose so that people can see what
it's like to live not in ukraine but as
they think we would live in russia
many blame the complex bureaucracy
enforced by ukrainian authorities
documents are scrutinized questions
asked belongings searched
since the conflict started it's often
been difficult for civilians to pass
from one side to the other they need a
special document for example to go
through this ukrainian checkpoint
but in the last few weeks things have
become much harder with a major road
into the nets closed due to fighting the
city is becoming more inaccessible
and just recently buses between the two
sides have also stopped running
transport authorities in donetsk say it
wasn't their decision
no one provided us with information or
official details we found out the bus
service was stopped on the day when it
actually happened they departed
according to plan but then they were
turned back
the only buses now leaving from donetsk
are to towns within rebel-held territory
and to destinations in russia
in recent days donetsk suffered fuel
shortages too with long lines at the few
gas stations which have fuel on tap
people are already getting used to it so
if we find fuel we fill the tank up as
well as a jerry can as reserved
the rebel authorities in donetsk blame
the transport problems on the ukrainian
government accusing kiev of imposing a
blockade
they say it's pushing them closer to
russia
and with supplies from ukraine cut off
supermarkets are mostly stocked with
russian goods
customers can even pay with russian
rubles
but selection is limited fresh milk is
in short supply at this store and some
shelves are empty
so people in the conflict area depend on
aid getting in but these red cross
trucks are slowed by military controls
too and as tensions continue between the
two sides transport across the line of
control is unlikely to improve
leaving civilians trapped in the middle